-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out with
one of the best to ever do it.
Helen Mirren, right there,
ladies and gentlemen!
That's what I'm talking about!
In a bubble bath!
You are so -- You are the best.
-I'm getting pinker and pinker.
-I love you.
I want to talk about "F9."
This is your third film in the
"Fast and Furious" franchise.
And I know you're not really
allowed to tell me much,
but I've seen, in the trailer,
you're driving, finally.
-I drive, finally.
-Yeah.
-Finally.
I begged to drive in the
first one and the second one.
They put me in the back of an
ambulance and then in jail,
so I had no chance of driving.
And I whined and moaned enough
that they finally let me drive.
But, wow, what a drive.
Incredible drive down the mall
towards Buckingham Palace.
The last time
I went to Buckingham Palace,
I was in the back of a taxi,
going to get my damehood.
-Wow! Isn't that wild.
What -- I mean,
is this true that
you went up to Vin Diesel at
some awards show or something
and you said,
"Hey, I love 'Fast and Furious.'
I know you produce it.
Get me in that thing."
-Oh, I did. No, I begged.
I was shameless.
No, absolutely.
I begged, I whined, I moaned,
I cried a little bit.
You know, I pulled every trick
that I could possibly pull, yes.
And he very, very kindly
acquiesced.
-Yeah, he's a good guy.
In the film, you play Queenie,
obviously, and that --
-Yes, Queenie named after
my auntie Queenie.
My mom came from
a big East End family.
There were 14 kids
in the family.
And, you know, West Ham,
for Londoners out there
know what that is.
So, it was a very old
London family.
And I had an Auntie Queenie.
And it's an old
East End name, Queenie.
So I thought that would be a
good name for her to have.
-I want to show everyone
a clip of you.
Here is Helen Mirren
and Vin Diesel in "F9."
Take a look at this.
-Well, it did go wrong on a crew
that just turned up,
led by an American.
[ Tires screech ]
♪♪
This geezer was
about your height, actually.
Similar features.
Oh, bloody hell.
He's not your cousin
or something, is he?
-He's my brother.
♪♪
[ Siren wailing ]
-Tether your brake
for me, would you, darling?
Glad I'm not the only one with
a family full of eccentrics.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is how
you do it right there!
That is how you do it!
Helen Mirren, everybody!
"F9" hits theaters
Friday, June 25th!